that's the sound of the annual Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade from Up Up and
Away preparing for its 96th run tomorrow
and that will take the streets of New
York City it couldn't go on without one
special connection here at home that's
right we're talking about Emily black
she is a UNLV graduate who lost her two
jobs because of the pandemic only to
emerge as a pivotal member of the parade
team Ryan Matthew joins us live in
studio with this amazing and really a
triumphant story right right you are
right Christian and Kirsten we have our
fair share of spectacles here in the
valley no doubt but none like this and
how many people can say they've helped
create the floats millions of people see
each year Well Emily black can and she's
ballooning with excitement that her dad
is part of the fun too this year
five thousand volunteers 12 marching
bands
16 giant balloons so that is the jenniel
float and 28 floats created by one of
Vegas's own stuff like is this real like
after being laid off and not having any
sort of prospects at all is this really
happening Emily black is an
entertainment engineer graduate from
UNLV her specialty staging Automation
and rigging she proved that while
working for multiple shows on the Las
Vegas Strip but after kova 19 hit that
work vanished us was essentially laid
off both jobs at around the same time
within a couple months of each other
yeah but it wasn't for long a recruiter
with Macy's Parade Studio founder on
LinkedIn being on the west coast I don't
think we know how big of a deal it is
she's now a senior engineer manager now
in her second year of Designing some of
the world's most viewed floats from
concept to Parade day she's part of it
all this year helping with the new
Wonder Bread Toys R Us and most
importantly this dragonflow why her dad
will be driving it I've driven a lot of
golf carts in Las Vegas her dad Michael
Black saying he was promoted from
balloon Handler to float driver this
year with his daughter's help my wife
and I are always finding ways to be
happy and proud of them so this parade
will be the top so far just to be able
to have my dad be in the parade and my
mom will be watching in the stands too
so it's just awesome to share that with
them
now in her previous job on the Strip
Emily says friends and family they
mostly did not get to see your work not
only will they get to see this work but
so will the entire world